Piro who's uh in Washington as well
director of Israel Palestine advocacy at
dawn a human rights and foreign policy
Think Tank he joins us as I said from
Washington and Adam I mean we don't want
to read too much into a tweet as it used
to be known of course but if this is a
shift a real shift not just in tone but
in Direction by the Biden Administration
by President Biden himself how
significant would that be given that we
are what 30 hours perhaps less than 30
hours away now from the end of this
ceasefire from the beginning potentially
of phase two of Israel's war on
Gaza well if if we are going to see a
shift and and I sincerely hope we do um
we do need more than just a tweet um we
do need to see concrete steps now there
are a number of options the
administration uh could take in terms of
trying to advance that um but part of
that I do believe has to be a more
forthright public position uh towards
Israel and towards this Israeli
government in terms of making it clear
that that not only can't Israel conduct
the war or War fighting uh as it's been
doing up until now um we have heard uh
the spokesman Kirby um kind of issue
these suggestions or Warnings but the
reality is is that the way the
population is in Gaza and increasingly
you know is now because of the
compression of the entire population
into a much smaller area it is virtually
impossible for Israel to conduct any War
fighting in Gaza against anything in
Gaza um that wouldn't result in severe
um consequences for the civilian
population whether it be um death
through the the actual bombardment um or
through ongoing humanitarian catastrophe
and and worse in The Who and others are
warning of the health consequences um if
the the war fighting begins again so
we're at a crucial juncture where the
Administration has to take concrete
steps to ensure that there's not going
to be any more fighting from the Israeli
side um if it's serious about trying to
to seek a different course at this point
well indeed it may be serious because of
the pressure building on it because of
splits as we were hearing there in
Congress splits in the party splits in
President Biden's support give me a
sense of the sort of tight RPP that this
President walks between his evident
determination up to now to support
Israel not to criticize Israel not to
call for an over ceas fire but at the
same time seeing how this is impacting
on his very support on his chances of
reelection well his his re-election is
is got to be Paramount consideration for
him his administration and and really
for the Democratic party and and the
consequences are severe I mean we know
what a trump Administration would look
like and and you know any of the other
Republican candidates don't promise much
better uh frankly for domestic policy
and for other policies um but in many
states around the country where the
election results are are going to be
close um it doesn't take a whole lot of
people to sit out an election and
therefore tip the the result one way or
another and what we know is that
President Biden won the last election in
a few key states by engaging younger
populations minority populations uh
women um and in some of those States um
you know for examp example Michigan
where there's a large Arab and Muslim
population and a large Palestinian
American population um those folks right
now find it extremely difficult to
consider voting for a president that
they believe has endorsed a genocide and
enabled a genocide um this is something
that the Biden Administration is going
to have to work very hard at changing uh
that perception and coming up with a a
policy that not only puts a halt to
what's happening but starts to undo the
damage and I think that's an extremely
tall order the big question of course on
the ground is if this is a discernable
new change uh in Direction in strategy
by the Biden Administration and if it
feeds into efforts Outreach efforts on
the ground we've got the Secretary of
State Anthony blinken uh in the region
we've got Bill Burns the CIA Chief here
in GA in Qatar no last meeting uh with
Qatari mediators and the uh head of
mosad uh the big question is will Israel
listen h I think this is a question not
just will Israel listen but will prime
minister Netanyahu listen and I think
this is in some ways as much as a
personal issue or personal political
issue for for President Biden it's even
more so for prime minister Netanyahu who
has faced calls for resignation for
stepping down continues to face those
calls is at legal legal Jeopardy for
previous uh matters that he's been
dealing with and um quite possibly could
be held accountable uh within the
Israeli system for the failures of under
his administration of October 7th in
terms of the intelligence and security
failures um that have been clearly
identified already by many in the
Israeli spe political Spectrum um and so
for him to for for pres prime minister
Netanyahu um there aren't too many off
ramps at this point that would seem to
be appealing and so for him personally
it may be his best interest and I hate
to say it this way but to his political
calculation maybe to continue
Prosecuting this this war fighting and
and that would be you know damaging not
just to obviously the Palestinians but
also to Israelis and and something must
be done to to stop that okay Adam sh
Shapiro at the human rights and foreign
policy Think Tank Dawn in Washington
many thanks for your time